et on va parler l'éducation maintenant
jean michel blanquer reluit la sueur
c'est une avancée inédite
le ministre de l'éducation a annoncé
hier que 700 millions d'euros seraient
alloués en 2022 à la revalorisation des
revenus des enseignants sur cette somme
400 millions d'euros vont prendre la
forme de nouvelles primes
une annonce à l'issue du grenelle de
l'éducation durant trois mois à écouter
le fou une enveloppe de 700 millions
d'euros sera dédié aux revalorisations
il y à 100 millions d'euros qui
permettront la montée en puissance des
mesures déjà décidées en 2021 400
millions d'euros pour mettre en oeuvre
les nouveaux engagements avec un travail
avec les représentants des personnels
qui se déroulera tout au long du mois de
juin pour prendre les décisions
adéquates notamment de répartition de la
façon dont nos répartition c'est 400
millions d'euros en particulier nous
avons toujours souhaité et revaloriser
les plus jeunes puisque c'est là où nous
constations le plus grand retard avec un
objectif sur une base pluriannuelle qui
est d'arriver à ce que dans d'ici
quelques années
et avant 2025 eh bien il n'y ait plus un
seul professeur qui gagnent moins de
2000 euros par mois
dans notre système scolaire et pour en
parler nous rejoignons jean rémy girard
il est président du syndicat national
des lycées et des collèges
bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france
une enveloppe de 700 millions d'euros
est ce que c'est conséquente selon vous
alors c'est pas zéro donc on va déjà
voix lactée néanmoins le ministre le
disait bien lui même
les images que vous avez montré avant en
réalité on n'est pas sur 700 millions
dont on va discuter on est sur 400
millions puisque il ya 200 millions
c'est la mutuelle pour la faire vite
c'est une mesure de la fonction publique
ça concerne pas spécifiquement les
enseignants et il ya 100 millions c'est
simplement pour acter les mesures de
cette année c'est à dire que
il existait déjà d'ailleurs on n'aurait
pas dû les comptabiliser donc on est
techniquement sur 400 millions d'euros
qui sont pas pour les enseignants qui
sont pour les personnels de l'éducation
nationale il ya des personnels non
enseignants qui vont toucher quelque
chose pour vous donner un des chiffres
simples que tout le monde comprenne bien
il ya en gros 1,2 million de personnels
à l'éducation nationale si vous faites
la division 400 millions d'euros 1,2
million en gros on est sur quelque chose
qui représente 30 euros par mois s'ils
ont revalorisé tout le monde de la même
façon
c'est en vrai c'est très très peu c'est
vrai que le chiffre de 400 millions sept
cent millions c'est des chiffres
médiatiquement impressionnant en réalité
sur la feuille de paye
c'est très très peu pour donner encore
un une idée les enseignants qui sont des
catégorie à des fonctionnaires la plus
la plus haute
voilà on est en moyenne payé 900 à 1000
euros de moins par mois que les autres
fonctionnaires de la catégorie dans la
fonction publique d'état
c'est à dire qu'en gros il faut encore
il faudra encore des mesures pour
arriver à a j'allais dire vraiment
augmenter tout ça il faudrait que l'on
tienne ce rythme là pendant plus de dix
ans pour que ça commence à ressembler à
quelque chose et on n'a aucune garantie
que ça va s'inscrire dans la durée
c'est aussi un autre point qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que nous le snalc
et tous les autres syndicats demandaient
une loi de programmation c'est à dire
qu'on puisse avoir une perspective à
long terme on s'achetait une
revalorisation qui s'enclenche sur le
long terme ça a été abandonnée
c'est ça a été acté hier il n'y a pas de
loi ça ne passera pas devant le
parlement
donc on discute de mesures font savoir
ce qui se passera après 2022 une annonce
de jean michel blanc car à l'essai d'un
grenelle dans l'éducation tel bilan vous
fait alors le grenelle de l'éducation ça
a été très long il faut le savoir et le
snalc et un syndicat qui a participé à
tous et qui restait et qui restait à
tous les tous les ateliers toutes les
réunions il y en a eu des tonnes et des
tonnes avec le co vide en plus tout
s'est fait à distance c'était très
pénible
ce grenelle il était là pour essayer de
créer une
voilà une sorte de mouvement au niveau
de la société mais surtout au niveau de
la représentation nationale des
parlementaires c'était quand même ça
l'objectif de départ c'était que les
robes la représentation nationale puisse
montrer son attachement à l'éducation
nationale aux enseignants aux autres
personnels et on se rend compte que ça
débouche sur rien de particulièrement
remarquable où on compte est
parfaitement le terme d' historique
alain weill art cette revalorisation qui
concernera pas tout le monde
il va falloir qu'on choisisse qui va
toucher de l'argent et qui ne va pas
chez le mois prochain
donc il ya des gens qui touchent pour
zéro pour quand même le savoir c'est à
dire qu'ils vont perdre le pouvoir
d'achat parce que l inflation da par
arrêté notamment le point d'indicé
toujours télé donc voilà on est sur
quelque chose qui est regrettable
on va faire évidemment ce qu'on peut
avec un blog qui est sur la table c'est
comme ça et là regardez en visant nous
intéressera on n'est pas idiot et voilà
c'est pas historique c'est pas
remarquable qui savent on fera pas des
enseignants on sait les enseignants les
mieux payés alors on s'attend à une
rentrée sociale compliquée en septembre
est ce que vu l'état d'esprit des
enseignants en cette fin d'année
scolaire justement est ce que vous
pensez vous que les enseignants vont
participer à cette rentrée sociale qui
s'annonce explosive pour nous c'est un
petit peu tôt pour le dire je vous avoue
les enseignants ici encore le nez dans
le guidon
actuellement ceux qui sont en lice et
sondés dans le baccalauréat dont les
épreuves terminales ont été maintenues
ceux qui sont au collège et à l'école
primaire au court jusqu'en juillet donc
on est
voilà on est en train d'essayer de gérer
la fin de cette année scolaire qui a été
très très fatigant pour tout le monde
pour les personnels pour les élèves pour
les parents on verra dans quel état
d'esprit on sera dans la rentrée de
septembre pour l'instant on n'est pas
soi on appelle à la grève donc ce soir
mais
on se réunira entre syndicats aussi pour
savoir où les uns et les rançons mais ce
qui est clair c'est que le fait d'avoir
abandonné cette idée d'une loi de
programmation que le fait d'attendre
toujours la fin des quinquennats pour se
dire oh mais il faudrait peut-être
revaloriser les enseignants ils sont pas
très bien payé
oui effectivement peut-être que il
faudrait s'en rendre compte dès le début
en fait ce serait beaucoup plus facile
et pratique où on est quand même un peu
fatigué de se rendre compte toujours que
l'année précédent l'élection
présidentielle on se souvient nous merci
merci beaucoup à vous jean réné girard
rappelle que vous êtes président du
syndicat national des lycées et des
collèges